hey leute was geht ab jetzt bekommt bei
einem neuen video hier mal wieder auf
meinem kanal und so ja erstmal so
aufgefallen ich habe schon ultralange
kein fragen und antworten video mehr
gemacht also irgendwie gab es ja mal so
ein format von mir dass ich in drei
minuten möglichst viele fragen wann
schafft das habe ich jetzt aber
irgendwie nicht mehr so konstant
durchgeführt und ich finde es auch
eigentlich scheiße es ist finde ich viel
besser weil ich einfach mal so auf eure
fragen eingehen kann und das will ich
heute auch einfach mal machen also ihr
habt wieder fleißig auf facebook frage
gestellt und was ich dazu noch sagen
wollte also ich bin ja soo mit dem
hälfte meiner abonnenten vielleicht auf
facebook befreundet die anderen diese
würden wir nicht auf facebook freunde
befreundet ihr also keine chance mehr
die frage zu stellen deswegen zeigt das
jetzt schon mal wenn ihr bock habt auch
eine frage zu stellen an beschreibt die
einfach unter dieses video in die
kommentare
würde mich auf jeden fall sehr freuen
ein kopf der bestimmt ins nächste fragen
und antworten video wenn ihr heute
gehabt so ich will gar nicht lange
lagern wir fangen direkt mal an und ich
wünsche ihnen natürlich ganz viel spaß
ja also die erste frage was schaust du
mehr fernsehen oder youtube ich würde
fast sagen das ist bei mir sogar
ausgeglichen ich schaue so am tag ich
würde mal sagen im durchschnitt zwei
stunden fernsehen und dann sitze ich
auch vier stunden am pc oder drei
stunden und davon verbringe ich fast die
komplette zeit auf youtube allerdings
gucke ich mir nicht immer videos an
sondern guckt einfach nur so ein
bisschen um deswegen würde ich sagen
manchmal so ein bisschen als ich den
fokus auch mal sein finde ich finde ich
ganz unterhaltsam
zumindest die eine oder andere sendung
und youtube ist natürlich auch mega geil
was war denn allererstes spiel was du
richtig gesucht hast also ich glaube das
war somit elf jahren oder so habe ich so
angefangen zu zocken und das erste spiel
sie war sogar fast süchtig würde ich mal
sagen dass hieß dark orbit jetzt mein
schreiben und sagen fall vielleicht
kennt kennt das die ein oder anderen von
euch
und wenn ich das jetzt drüber nachdenke
dass ich das so gezockt aber wohl das
spiel einfach überhaupt keinen sinn
ergibt das ist das beschissene
browsergame das ich jemals gesehen habe
also fallen damit jährlich an
nächste frage einfach fan anrufe also
ich habe schon mal darüber nachgedacht
ob das auch mal machen soll
und da ist ja eigentlich eine coole
sache auf jeden fall wenn jemand dafür
seid dann gebt dem video doch einfach
mal daumen hoch oder schreibe es in die
kommentare keine ahnung wenn ihr mal
wollte sich euch anrufe oder die nächste
frage was macht ihr am meisten einen
youtube spaß
ich finde man kann das wort spaß und das
wort motivation wenn das jetzt auf
youtube bezogen ist in den gleichen oder
in denselben gedanken bereich übertragen
falls jetzt grammatikalisch richtig
ausgedrückt war auf jeden fall finde ich
das geld oder was auch so den spaß auf
jeden fall wird es ist dass das man so
immer sieht oder bei mir total heftig zu
zeigen dass ich im vergleich zu zeit
davor dass ich merke dass meine
community wächst und wächst also das
kann man somit betrachten wie man halt
oder wie die community wächst wie man
mehr kommentare krieg die videos wieder
öfter angeschaut werden und das bringt
einem halt auch so die motivation und
auch vor allen den spaß also das ist so
der meister oder der größte spaß faktor
würde ich mal sagen und dann kommt man
zur nächsten frage lieblings sprach also
was ist deine lieblings sprache denkmal
ich würde sagen englisch finde ich
irgendwie cool die aussprache das wird
sich alles so richtig cool an
und ja eigentlich mag ich eigentlich
ziemlich toll und spannend bis vibriert
jetzt ich bin jetzt wieder auf ask
unterwegs so ein bisschen als mau jetzt
angelina hat mehrere fragen gestellt ich
beantworte davon jetzt einfach mal nur
eine weil die anderen fragen möchte ich
auch noch ganz gerne beantworten
und ja ich nehme jetzt einfach mal hier
wie bist du so in der schule ja ich
würde mal sagen ich bin so ein
durchschnittlicher schüler vielleicht
sogar etwas über dem durchschnitt
kein name ich hatte 24 ich weiß ja nicht
mehr das ist so ungefähr durchschnitt
also ich bin jetzt nicht so der der nur
scheiße baut ich bin jetzt nicht so der
der nur einzeln schreibt oder so sondern
mehr so dazwischen irgendwie manchmal
bin ich besser manche schlechter also so
ausgeprägt seit die jungs echt so
oberflächlich wie manche tun und nord
aussehen und figur achten
ja es gibt auf jeden fall welche diese
die so denken dass oft und so sagen und
halt ein bisschen so rüberkommen aber es
gibt auch welche die sind ganz normalen
und ganz cool also würde mal sagen das
auch so 50 50 oder so die einzeln er so
und die anderen er sucht so so so so so
was haben wir genau
würdest du lieber eine woche keine zähne
putzen oder nie wieder schokolade ist
keine ahnung nach habe ich hier gegen
wieso ich würde dann lieber er eine
woche keine zähne putzen auch wenn ich
dann zum zahnarzt muss und er nie
irgendwas geboren muss oder so dass
nämlich deinem kopf eben kauf bei
schokolade mag ich schon richtig gerne
und darauf kann ich glaube ich nicht so
lange verzichten so letzte frage für
heute
hättest du lieber zehn piercings im
gesicht oder einen riesen hello kitty
kat uhr am bauch ja auf jeden fall
schwere frage bzw schwer darauf eine
antwort zu finden
aber ich würde fast sagen sondern so ein
hello kitty to go und dafür nicht mehr
so oft uns frei wird gehen oder er gar
nicht mehr beim 14 sie sieht man ja
immer und ich finde dass sie so brutal
aus hat man ein piercing oder einer
gegner aber wenn man wie jesu piercings
hat dann sieht man aus wie so ein
aggressiver typ und das bin ich nicht
so leute und das fazit zum teil schon
wieder mit diesem video und soja ich
habe auf jeden fall jetzt öfter vor eure
fragen mal wieder zu beantworten also
ich hoffe ihr freut euch drüber und ihr
schreibt jetzt endlich fragen und in die
kommentare ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich
das video hat euch gefallen also gebt
doch einfach mal daumen nach oben man
sich ganz so gefallen hat auch einfach
daumen nach oben und ja in der
beschreibung findet ihr noch links zu
instagram und co abonnieren nicht
vergessen wenn nix mehr verpassen wollt
und hinten links geht es jetzt weiter
mit meinem letzten video das war so eine
story gewöhnt mit so2 besoffenen typen
und hier unten rechts mit meinem
vorletzten video dinge die du niemals zu
deiner freundin sagen solltest checkers
auf jeden fall beides mal ab und wir
sehen uns dann am wochenende wieder
schönen schöne
woche noch oder bis samstag haut rein